our first guest has arrived we're just
talking about joe barton
did you see the dick photo the photo of
him he had to step down
that was the guy it's a good angle
though that's not a good pick
no you got it all right i put on five
hold on of course she did yes i did
hi welcome anthony terrible angle did
you see uh
you see his text though it makes it
better i want you so
bad right now deep in heart oh no
why do you say deep and hard like i want
you
deep and hard he wants that's what she
wants [__] she wants him to
she wants her he wants her to penetrate
him yeah that's what it sounds like
that's what it how it reads
yeah it's not a good angle it's not a
flattering angle no not at all there's a
big
gut hanging out like that oh that's
terrible
look at the titties rolling over the gut
[Laughter]
his lip is like like you know the lip
he's like he's trying to get the angle
right
he's like mr christian that is a
terrible one he's tense in that lower
jaw because he's so excited yeah he's
just trying to get the angle of this
[__]
top to bottom bad do you send dick
photos or no have you ever
i have yeah yeah to uh some trusting
souls
trust me that i've uh with your friends
never know no
never you usually make really uh good
decisions in your love life so i would
imagine that these were
only the people that you absolutely
trusted especially after a few
beverages which is always
when you do that right you don't wake up
in the morning go oh
i think i'm going to send some dick pics
today speak for yourself
[Laughter]
you wake up kind of fluffed up like yeah
yeah yeah
i'm of conscious mind first thing i do i
love it oh it's
always after a night you're drinking and
you're texting or something back and
forth and then you just
yeah why not it seems like a good idea
the relationship uh on social media just
goes so quickly
it goes from hi how you doing to you're
just looking at [__] and you're sending
dick pics out
like in a bar atmosphere that would be
like 2 a.m
you want to see it by 2 a.m you'd be hey
you want to go to the bathroom and show
each other you know
our [__] yeah what i do well you send it
through i won't send pictures through
like a twitter
dm or anything no that's a crazy place
nothing like that
it's just got to be texts and uh yeah
that's why it's more private
and i haven't done it in a long time
like i'm
it's just too [__] nuts out there now
what's wrong with the direct message
because your name your app mention is
attached to it or because you might
accidentally tweet it yeah
it could just be it's just asking it's
trouble brewing yeah
trouble she's already in the twitter app
so she might as well just share this
with the world just share it with other
people
and or that or it could just somehow be
hacked or something i
i don't know you could accidentally
tweet it's more a lot of times i'm
worried that i would [__] that up
and somehow hit something wrong i mean
it's just a dick picture i mean i don't
think anyone care if my dick came it's
not a
i've never sent anybody to some anything
to somebody accidentally thinking i was
sending it to someone else
that would be so stupid it never
happened it hasn't happened to him
either
i couldn't even look at him on the
elevator
[Laughter]
how you guys doing good yeah very good i
was just uh telling the lovely travis uh
the the commuting thing is just i i
i can't do it it's train it's the
morning yeah
so i have to take the train and then the
subway and there's the little walking in
between and everything
the train the inane [__] train
conversation
is what i hate just sit down shut the
[__] up
and and and enjoy your hellish ride yeah
but these they're
they're you're now in the hours where
it's train buddies oh
god i hate that they're getting on and
have you have you seen the like because
i used to i
can't i had buddies yeah me too i had to
stop doing it like i just
just start driving in and just dealing
with the traffic yeah because i couldn't
handle the train anymore
what really did it was the weird like
non-sexual but sexual tension between
the train like
husband and wife where it's the it's
like the the beaten
guy who sits down with the not terribly
attractive woman
but they have this weird flirtatious a
little not really
expectation been cooking for a while
because they take the same training
every morning
but it just exists in their 35 minutes
on the train
and that's the relationship every day i
can't stand it when i was at the train
station
it was a [__] a little more people than
usual when i go i leave my house at like
2 00
p.m and the train sometimes literally
it's there just for me
i'm like this is the best thing i paid
you know relatively small amount
for an entire train to stop for me
twilight zone episodes just going in a
circle will it be
and uh and when it when it's crowded
like this
i'm standing at the station and i'm i'm
hearing like good morning
hi how you doing like they know each
other just for that
kid shut up you're not happy ate them
[Laughter]
so miserable this way i was just looking
around like
if people catch me they could see that
i'm just looking like
i hate you i hate this
my my wife dropped me at the train once
when i was uh when i was taking the
morning train and the dog was in the
back seat
and so the dog was barking as i was
going into the train right and
this woman goes oh he's saying goodbye
to you
oh god and i was like oh yeah ha ha i
just avoided conversation all together
little did i know that i had established
a relationship
oh that's all it takes for weeks how's
the dog
all she brought me a goddamn brochure
about dogs at one point
that is a lonely ass [__] person it
was terrible you should have done this
shut her up when she handed that you she
said i'm gonna go jerk off to this
it's pretty hot what kind of dog is it
oh they're
very very you know she loves you she was
saying goodbye that's what she was doing
when she was barking
oh really really my god
it's so [__] just the the babble that
goes on between the seats and everything
and i'm just
i'm shoved into a corner just trying to
get as far away from everybody as
possible with your big jacket on it
yeah big jacket i'm i'm like my phone is
right against my face and i'm just
peering over the top of it with hatred
you're not participating in the morning
banter
oh the banter about the the news the big
water cooler story of the day
no i'm hoping it's a derailment right
underneath me
it is amazing like when you throw
yourself into the world you don't want
to be in
yeah which is that world or just the
office it's [__] horrible
yeah thank god that's not my life like i
don't have to do that
i know that's what i think like when i'm
in that situation i know that
you know when i'm done with this today
yeah i'm gonna go to my apartment go to
sleep for like four hours
and then do my show for two hours and
then i'll go home
oh no i got chipper oh boy i got chippa
later on
which is always fun i love doing that he
loves you
oh chip is great chip has grown on me so
much
we we share a sense of humor i've
finally been able to figure out
the chemistry though i got that
chemistry
you will when you're in one of those
situations look around the train and
realize like you get to this place where
you're like if the train crashed and we
all died
i'd be okay like yeah there would be
somebody right before i died
i'd look around and see everybody else
burning and go okay
yeah if i could see someone's head smash
into one of those
two-ton doors or something that that
wouldn't be too bad i guess
okay that's the last thing you saw on
your way out yeah
yeah whatever yeah i remember when i was
going to summer school when i was a boy
in high school i used to take the bus
every day to new brunswick
and there was a woman who would get on
she was a nurse and every day i would
try to look up her skirt
of course i used to think how old were
you
22. no i was a kid i was 14. i was
15 i was like a freshman in high school
or sophomore you were a freshman i
certainly i
was i was a fresh boy yes you were
trying to pick up she's like a jamaican
lady
i had to go to summer school for french
looks like a wallet
and i would stare at her legs and i
would try to look up her skirt i always
thought she was trying to show me
uh but then again i might have been
probably that's that's i bet that's what
everybody says
she wanted me to jerk off in front of
her on the train that's that's
no she didn't like that all the guys
that like stop looking at me white boy
can't you see i got an afghan over me
legs
all the guys that like to like rub
themselves on women and jerk off in
front of women like they
all fantasize i think they believe that
yeah i think a lot of the
because we're hearing all kinds of
stories there was that another
politician that shoved a woman into a
bathroom and just started jerking off
and i honestly believe they think that
once they start doing it the girls can
be like oh
well i've never seen this approach
before but it works
yeah and no they don't want you to jerk
off in front of them no i've told you
before when
when when uh jess was in i think she was
in france she was studying or something
and some guy was rubbing his boner on
her on the train oh my god
she sure wasn't a baguette they always
had in a bag with some celery
but she's like and she's a get [__]
and she's you know she's five foot
nothing she's just yeah and she turns
around
and just points her little finger in the
guy's face and goes nobody likes that
wow and the guy like was like shocked he
was like paralyzed
ugh because she ruined every [__]
american
yes yes yeah
ugly americans how many times have you
heard that in the bedroom
[Laughter]
failing erection nobody likes that no i
know
that's a great way to do it though yeah
i mean a lot of times
if you're just like nobody likes that a
little bit of uh
assertiveness and stuff like that
because i think those guys are
very um you know shy yeah strangely
enough
i think they will back off in a second
if a girl goes up to them and actually
uh gives them a little [__] about it
well didn't we watch a video bless you
one of the shows we all did once
didn't we watch like uh uh one of the
guys getting called out for jerking off
on the train
we started one of them
yeah it was right there one guy in
philadelphia i think yeah the woman has
like her camera in the face like look at
what you're [__]
doing look at you and he just like you
see it all over his face he's just
head down and yeah he came he did he did
come when she was scolding him
you could see him come or something and
then he's like so ashamed yeah
it was a really weird moment i can't
even imagine i was i was saying uh uh
the other day like i can understand if
you're
you're a little tanked up you're with
your girl you get into a little mutual
masturbation or something sure
uh you know but but the girl
has to be so into it for for you to even
think that you're gonna stand there and
pound your pud in front of you yeah like
even the louis ck thing i can't imagine
two girls just kind of sitting there
kind of chuckling even i'd be a little
embarrassed it's so embarrassing
like i i don't get it yeah
i would i would feel kind of silly yeah
i like your girl pinching my nipples
when i do it do you ever give the old
nips a tweak
[Laughter]
why don't you tweak the old nipperoos
troy do you like
do you like nipple playing no
i love when jim brings it up because
like you pull the room i've never been
in a room that i could poll that anybody
else
that you don't like your nipples tweaked
no
no not at all you like nipple play no
of course not it's not even a thought
just try no no not at all
no it's just uh you guys it's
uncomfortable
it isn't even that it's not pleasurable
it's the opposite of pleasure
and yes it removes pleasure i love my
nipples lightly played with
i've heard that i know i've talked about
it but it's yeah it's one of those
moments where it's like what are you
what are you doing
get away get away why are you doing that
no get away from that tickles
a slight brush over it while they're
going somewhere else is fine
sure yeah you know you're in route to
my dick or something right but not
not that
[Laughter]
a mouthful of sharing yeah do you ever
kiss a girl after you blow alone in your
mouth that's terrible
no that's awful terrible i've done it
it's it's awful you don't like it
no no no has a girl ever kissed you
after she blew a load in your mouth
that's a good point yes
that's totally different okay that's not
uh
good yeah i don't like that no your own
comma is great in theory
why you know when you're [__] you're
being dirty like that one girl would
tell me to lick you come up i was like
yeah i am and then as soon as you come
you're like
well they said the problem is after you
come your
whole attitude about the whole act that
you're doing and everything it changes
you're done
you're done so now the idea of doing
anything like that is a little um
crazy it's like talking dirty about
brussels sprouts while you're eating
chocolate cake
as soon as you don't eat your cakes like
you have time for those sprouts sprouts
coming up not happening i'm a little
full thing
very satisfied no i would i would still
say even even
in theory i don't think my own ejaculate
is something that i look at at all like
ooh yeah no
like even in the spur of the moment if
somebody was like sperm at the moment
oh anthony [__] yeah
yeah even in in that and that's i
wouldn't be like i'd be like oh yeah and
then you'll look it up i'd be like no
i'm not gonna do that
sometimes it just gets everywhere and
and you know you could be kissing a
girl's neck
and you're like wow [__] is that a
humble break got a little
yeah it is a little bit
because mine is in a is in a specific
pool like it's very nice
it's very easy to locate a little
drizzler a little bit it's not yeah
there's no
there's no ropes i shot myself in the
cheek
i do this thing when i really wish you
would i do
oh i saw a video like that just go back
to your other store i was jerking off
and i have a i was just talking this
yeah i have [__] i had like a shirt
on
so i had lobster paper towels
he's a messy eater thank you and i
[__] hit myself in the cheek it was a
[__]
dollop of calm on my wow what'd you do
with it i wiped it off
that's pretty good pretty good
trajectory
yeah i was really good i've been in good
form like formula
four yeah were you happy with yourself
yeah i'm back to lube again not that
anybody cares
i'm trying to use lube again and get my
sensitivity back when you jerk off you
use lube yeah my dick right now is the
sensitivity of an
ankle guy
trying to fix it again you really need a
lot of uh
just lightly doing it yeah a lot of
outside things to sensitize and
yeah it's been so many years i'm just
trying to be normal again and just jerk
off like a regular guy
good lube yeah that's good for [__] 10
hours straight
no just lightly like toying oh it's
unpleasant
yes not a lot of edging just a lot of
information
good good get it over with yeah back to
doing something
important get it done all right yeah ten
minutes is good
yeah it is yeah just done done yeah and
then
that's not now i can get back to just
thinking clearly
yeah what's sexier than a good dirty
picture though when you get one
jim is so naughty you know you just
don't want to uh you don't want to
finish it
is there anything better though nothing
worse than when you just start hearing
outside there's like birds oh cause
you've been messing
it's like wait oh no it's morning
when you're jerking you mean jerking off
so long that the sunlight comes up the
sun is coming in you're like oh
this is this is despicable yeah
yeah there's a bad feeling it's not a
piece of [__] when someone comes over
you don't want over
and you're like oh you can stay over
then as soon as you come you're like why
did i say
why have you ever had someone over that
you regretted
a couple of times yeah yeah definitely
yeah
yeah what do you do do you you've never
thrown them out though
no because you just kind of have to you
made the arrangement i mean yeah you
have to go with the commitment you've
made
right you know yeah you they stay and
then that's
we reap what we sow sometimes yes we do
[Laughter]
um terrible yeah
i thought people were calling in to talk
about uh well
see i thought people calling in to talk
about jerking off yeah
but then one of the callers said he had
an idea for a viral video and now i'm
afraid that he wants to make videos i'm
jerking all the time yeah
yeah i don't want to do that i don't
know what uh what is that question do
you know
which one number three does that know oh
i don't uh let me just say
uh
i don't know oh i think he just wants uh
like me
and apollo and like everybody to do
and you and everything to do one show
somewhere oh where everybody likes
insults
perfect sense or just uh hold on yeah uh
bill what ability talking about friends
oh bill
boy and yes anthony remembers the
question
i asked him on nick apollo show getting
everybody there
and make sure you got rich moss and a
lit
bit of lego zombo there for him
and just uh doing the most vicious show
ever again
what are you talking about i think just
getting a room full of comics and
uh you know cutting loose is as they say
i see
loose all right thank you bill
everybody's just riffing
oh yeah hey look at that yellow
sweatshirt over there what are you
covered in tinkle
uh that's a good one nailed them
not yellow what is it it's beige oh
i uh i watched i watched a film
last night a film with the
the wonderful jim norton was in a little
bit spider-man
the comedian i had not seen it
i saw it is that why you came in here
with all the great jokes
look i love jimmy di paulo yeah yeah you
guys what do you mean so
[__] cool and fun you get such a
great
shot too right there yeah uh and then
how's your ass that was a funny line
not only hey jackie how's your [__]
that's your [__]
i saw him at the premiere and he walked
up to me and he goes hey how's your
[__] that's your
ass oh was that ad-libbed uh yes yes
that's awesome that was very funny um
but the rest of oh boy you liked it i'd
heard things
and then as i watched it i'm just
sitting there really
saying to myself why am i continuing
wasn't that good why
i didn't find it that good you found
there was a
a couple of flaws uh
and boy when they try to get an actor to
do
stand-up comedy it really just shows
people
how amazing it is that people can do it
stand-up is a weird thing to play like
when you're playing there's a weird
you know when someone does it and when
they don't um
dude an actor can play anything else
a good actor can go on
in front of a camera and perform and
play a doctor
or a pilot or a cop or that or or a sad
guy or a lunatic or some
the second they try to portray a
stand-up comic
they not only miss but by a [__] mile
how was it was hankson punchline he he's
you know he did it
and sally field doesn't really count she
was playing but but he was okay
it i don't know if it's the punchline
was terrible no no no no no no no i'm
saying him as
the idea of him performing stand up
being a cop he's a good actor but like
the whole meltdown yeah yeah i didn't
buy the meltdown
uh hoffman is lenny bruce if i don't
it's been many years since i've seen
that but i think he was okay is that i
don't remember it
it's just not it's not like you're
watching a comic
right you can't get that like i've
watched actors portraying different
people and so
and i've been taken right in and go wow
that's you know that's amazing like ben
affleck his performance
oh amazing but is it though because
someone's so famous
because when i watch when you watch the
king of comedy and at the end rupert
pumpkin does stand up
he's better than you expect him to be
like he's not terrible he's
okay like you expect him to be a
disaster and his jokes
i'm from poseidon they were like not
great
but they were okay which i thought was
the greatest part of that was that his
jokes were okay
de niro's delivery is just abominable
it's so hard to watch and and he did
pull out rupert pumkin a couple of times
in the comedian
i saw him doing some some mannerisms and
stuff that i was like my god that's like
king of comedy
rupert pumpkin but uh just it's it's
that special a thing it's a weird thing
to to
when you when you watch people talk this
i guess there's a rhythm that comes with
it
yeah or or something i don't know what
it is
because uh people have said how come
actors have a harder time with that and
i don't know what it is it's almost like
playing a singer in a way
like if you take someone and say okay
now you play a singer even if your voice
is okay if you have to go out there and
try to sing and you've never sang before
yeah or it's like where it's like doing
karate you can't just like
do karate you can't just all of a sudden
start doing yeah like if you play
this guy who does karate in a movie it's
kind of hard just to do karate but there
are things you can do to make it look
like the actors doing amazing karate
yeah yeah and things like there's but
there's no trick
there's no nothing anybody can do to an
actor
to make you go wow that's a great
stand-up and i've seen
stand-ups that are really good actors
jim thanks a lot buddy i appreciate that
thank you yeah there are some some
stand-ups that are just really good
actors
well i said i played uh you know i had
to do a little something recent i've
told you what it was yes
yes very excited well let's just say i
had to play someone in a nightclub
setting
right do you see uh funny people
no i did not judge how still not
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's the movie that like they were
doing
actual stand-up sets yeah and shooting
them like not necessarily like they
would go to clubs
and have like seth rogen and and
apatow started doing them again that's
when he started doing stand-up again
like they
actually would go to comedy clubs and
put together 15 minutes
yeah that's more of isn't that more of
just comics doing their act
like instead of yeah i've seen some
comics in movies have to play themselves
doing
their act right and they're not good at
it it's weird they
they freeze up or something in the in
the comedian there was a scene where
everyone was just doing stand up which
they showed at the village underground
and it was just comics just doing sp
they're just the comedians doing right
stand up
yeah yours yours was hilarious they they
ended that scene with your
uh with your jokes i wasn't supposed to
be in that scene
i literally they called me down just to
host that um
while uh they were shooting de niro
doing walking but him and edie
falco were in the audience walking i
wasn't even supposed to be filmed
it was uh it was funny it was the uh the
incest bit with the mom
on the phone yeah the phone rings it's
like mom you're right next to me
i think i just i think i just ripped
that i like that it's very very i want
to do like topical stuff
just do uh whatever silly it was it was
just she was very funny
yeah it was late falcao yeah she was
like
it was very weird i was doing i was
doing stand up and dinner was walking
back and forth
if they were filming him yeah yeah and
i'm just doing my act and then they turn
the camera around they let me
host the show that's uh i was noticing
those shots too where de niro's kind of
walking outside the cellar and it's kind
of
it's like oh god this is so corny it's a
little it was a little corny
they supposed to be an older comic i
understand yeah
yeah i i i get it um do you think the
viral videos were good
you know the viral videos uh not
particularly great but they kind of show
how shitty viral videos
can be that's what goes viral yeah that
is dog [__]
the the poopy video oh god
i was cringing yeah that is the type of
thing that would get a lot of views
certainly one you'd hate it morons
people would watch it a lot oh they
would oh this is good
i like eddie falco i should have took a
picture with her oh you did it i'm
missing the point no
oh i didn't carmella soprano you're the
best
you don't like her what why don't you
like her i said the best misunderstood
we were just talking about this pranos
yesterday because i spent a lot of the
weekend
watching season three again oh it's just
awesome it's the best show of all time
i can't even get enough of it no i can't
either i watched the
pilot episode a couple of days back just
to kind of
see what it looked like before they
really got established
like the characters are different we
talked about that yeah facing of the
show was different
two years before it was that shell for
two years oh yeah again feni sounds
different you could tell
he sounds like when he's that kevin
finnerty guy when he's
in the coma yeah like that's what he
sounds like his normal kind of voice
um and he's a lot thinner that's right
he got a lot more hair on his head
and that was the pilot and then two
years later they shoot the series and
he's already
kind of a fat piece of [__]
he's got the [__] voice uh going yeah
he did change it from from the pilot
that's amazing that sat for two years
yeah that pilot set
that's the kind of things that uh really
do amaze me in in show business like
because they must have been like oh yeah
i shot a pilot and yeah nothing went
nowhere
a mafia show about ducks yeah sure yeah
and then it's the the one of the biggest
shows ever ever
you ever see all in the family
three pilots they went through the two
pilots they went through and the third
one was finally the one that went
really yeah they had different i think a
different gloria or the you know but
that took a couple of years to go
through that didn't just get picked up
in all the scenarios
well they don't give anything time now
you know no if
they don't like the idea uh it's done
right off the bat did you see what you
talking about
dustin hopman did you see the clip of
him and john oliver is that clip
available or no we just have the
audience
we have the transformation why would i
even watch that
i i don't watch john oliver but i mean
he's like but the whole sexual thing
oh yeah so john oliver was hosting a
thing at the 92nd street y
last night oh oh that's where that was
okay and it was uh i think they were
playing wag the dog
and had a bunch of the cast there they
were doing one of those talks
yeah dustin hoffman was one of them and
uh in the middle of the
discussion john oliver brings up that i
guess dustin hoffman is one of the
people that's been accused of
sexual misconduct well it was more for
comments that were made about
the this girl who was like an intern or
something he was just
he i think he thought he was being like
just joking around and talking [__] on
the set and being like
right i don't know if he saw it as
seriously as she did but apparently he
got very very testy between the two of
them
his testies
oh wait oh there's video oh
groping 17 year old intern oops but
there's a key
word that's left out the quote
that goes around the world clip is like
six minutes oh do you want to maybe find
it and then we can play it after yeah
yeah so apparently like uh john oliver
brings it up and it gets
tense and kind of weird and then john
oliver kind of okay let's
brings it back to the movie or whatever
else they're talking about
and five minutes later dustin hoffman
brought it up again because he was so
pissed
he was pissed at john oliver oh he was
just stewing during that five minutes
i'm sure
yeah he said something like you've uh
you you've made uh huge judgments on me
or something like that you know the
they just have like no ability
for any kind of self uh
responsibility or anything
self-awareness
the actors actors they they've been
coddled that's what it is
so many years that when they're called
out on something and someone really
points at them and says hey [__]
they are like what
do you know who i am and even if you're
just asking a lot of times they don't
know how to just give you like an answer
no no here's what happened no they just
they could again they're used to
somebody else answering
the publicist standing there waiting to
cut you off from asking the [__]
question
yeah they don't usually handle that
stuff very well at all no they don't
you got it right it's a little hard to
hear but i do have it
because it's okay that part of it i'm
not i'm
not the moral officer of anything it's
just it's not reflective of who i
am it's that kind of response to this
stuff that
pisses me off because
it is reflective of
who you were if it happened and you'd
given no
evidence to show that it didn't happen
then there was a period in time for a
while when you were creeping
around women so it feels like a cop out
to say well this isn't me do you
understand how that feels
[__] you you limey [__] it's difficult
to answer that question
you weren't there you didn't i'm glad
he said i'm glad i was out there glad
yeah it's like let him answer
he's poking at him yeah i guess so he
also knows that this is a
you know he did at one point ask the
audience to stop recording it with your
cell phones
oh stop it oh really and then everybody
was like why would you do it on stage
with microphones if you didn't watch
that
stop at your goose what the [__] people
are out of their
minds this is just recording it don't
record this is a private conversation
between me and you and everybody here at
the 90 second stream
yeah me and a thousand people here let's
just keep it under our hats yeah shut up
it should be the 97th street what where
yeah what wxz
[__] yeah [__] letters
just two different directions just yeah
totally separate oh
magic tonight oh of course so rich is
joining us
supposedly uh yeah voss says he will be
on this program you know what chip
should do chip should
i hope that chip has seen this john
oliver clip and chip should try to call
out vos
for his sexual misconduct that's right
and really try to get some buzz going
yeah
yeah foss hasn't done anything should we
say the thing that vos did or should we
save that
well we have to wait till tomorrow okay
cause i you know what's all i've been
thinking about it's all i've been
thinking okay well i'll tell you i'll
tell you during the break
okay we'll save it for tomorrow i won't
sperl it um
so whatever so uh uh so yeah do you have
more of this uh dustin hoffman thing
well did he actually did they come to a
do they make up or no
no do they make up are they friends
again
he must be very uh angry at john oliver
human yeah because you're trapped yeah
yeah you're on a stage like we're here
to talk about wag the dog right
i thought we were here to discuss the
film even though john oliver kind of
came at him he didn't just ask he came
in i'm like with absolutely
this is correct this is what happened he
came at him with judgment for sure
yeah like he's saying you aren't there
and he's like i'm glad
what's like what does that mean that's
all of these celebrities though
like hey you aren't there you don't know
what happened like they're they don't
see it as they have done anything wrong
although
although it does also sound like what
roy moore is saying oh yeah yeah
well don't get on the great judge roy
moore
the honorable judge roy moore you mean
go get him roy
go go get him roy
unhorrible
[__] it i thought when when trump just
started running for president i was like
this is going to be great and then when
it
when he won it was like i can't believe
how much fun this is going to be
it has been so much more fun than i even
dreamt it would be it is
way crazier than i think any of us could
have imagined
everyone's lost their [__] minds yeah
and i
can't be happier about it to the point
where it's like on one end you're like
okay we want to impeach him we want to
impeach him
and then the news who gets accused of
being fake
comes out and they go we've got the
smoking gun yeah we're going to get him
and then you see the club with joy behar
oh andrew
is on tv and she's celebrating like yeah
we got him
and then the news who supposedly hates
trump
because he keeps calling him fake news
has to come out and say
oh we made a mistake that was fake fake
news
fake news it's every day
every [__] day there's something else
twitter's a light with all of it the
news
depending on what station you're on it's
just
mass insanity and you're only a quarter
of the way through oh
at least thank god it seems to me like
the inmates are running the asylum
wow isn't it going to get any easier the
deep
thinking i've seen in jim lately it's
cool man he's not just a comedian
no no that is certainly not is it even
wrong
it's been so it is nuts crazy
you couldn't imagine and people off the
rails people have forgotten
like this philosophy of like okay like
this person is where he's at you don't
like it that's fine
right but with a guy like trump you can
let him dig his own grave
like you can let him do it to himself
but everybody is so eager
to be like we got you we got you they're
just chasing their tails and making
themselves look like ass but it's not
even a gravy's digging no there's a hole
in stands and anything just jumps out
exactly and there have been how many
things
since he started running were supposed
to absolutely sink him
like this is the one oh my god he
[__] finished
yeah i mean remember the billy bush
thing and now billy bush is on talk
shows going
hey trump you idiot trying to ingratiate
himself
with the liberal media so he's sitting
there trying to
uh get back and and he's the ass all in
the whole thing yeah
trump is the president he's the [__]
in the whole thing here's what's great
trump is the president billy bush got
fired there's literally
an opening for a male host
at the show that billy bush was working
for matt lauer
is gone billy bush would have gotten
that job if he hadn't gotten fired
a 100 you know yeah yeah and he's not
getting the cake now
oh it would have happened yeah
and then just trying to predict who's
next like that's
that's what everybody tries to do but
they're pulling them out of nowhere and
everywhere because you don't know
anything about we don't know anything
about
dustin hopkins like that thing i never
would have guessed kevin spacey i knew
was gabe i never heard
the underage [__] like the underage yeah
really predatorial stuff
and you don't know yeah you just uh
but with trump it's like it's not it's
not only like he jumps out of the hole
because they do like what abc news did
which is just
[__] up again it's like they dig a hole
for donald trump
they shove him into it and then at the
very last minute they throw a ladder
to him or yeah come on out or or it's
like uh
the roadrunner coyote uh thing where the
coyote will paint a tunnel on a wall
right and uh think uh that trump is just
gonna smash into it
trump goes through it and then they go
to chase him and smash in the wall
that's exactly what he's doing he's just
you can't
do anything to him no because we all
know he's
batshit nuts he's a womanizer he loves
[__]
young attractive women uh
he's he's a little kooky right and but
but
and so what are they going to call them
out on teflon they're taking teflon
they're spraying on that pan every time
they skip a piece of food on that dance
is right out of the old teflon man
deep chest metaphors are no
good you know that's kind of like
that was good no it was
stupid
yeah sometimes it works but that's that
is
yeah that is what's happening he's just
and i think it's because people going
after him
are so especially in the media like in
the news are so
emotional it's all emotion yeah it's a
pure emotion because that's when people
[__] up like think about every
fight that you've been in in a
relationship like you find yourself
how did i get into this hole that i dug
myself into and it's because like
you got all angry or or or whatever like
you were
it's just emotional one thing you
shouldn't have said and then forget it
it spirals out of control that's it
right
yeah you're talking about like hey i was
supposed to be there at eight i got
there at 8 30.
and then five minutes later you scream
your grandmother's a contest she's
shaking her shoulders
you can't take that one back yeah no
that was good i would have been there in
a while
it's gonna linger a while i guess you
just can't
uh they they are so emotional
um the people trying to get trump out of
impeachment that the celebrities
i uh the rosie o'donnell tweets are just
sad only rosie o'donnell like rosie
is like you're done trump you're gone
this is over you're done this is the
latest news and you're gonna be going to
jail it's like he's
he's not he's not done he's not going to
jail
he's not i watched a great uh
documentary oddly enough on headline
news which is cnn and it was on the uh
clinton
lewinsky thing what happened and well
let me tell you buckle in because it's a
hoot
uh and and he was uh
found guilty of lying to
to the fbi and uh perjury and
uh obstruction of justice they impeach
him he was actually impeached
and he finished out his terms but then
he went to jail after that
no see i think you're thinking
right yeah so all of this stuff they
they've gone
like over a year and and found nothing
like
nothing on trump they're putting all
their eggs in the flynn basket
it's like oh flynn and flynn is gonna
talk to the
no this they have nothing on this guy
you obviously haven't watched keith
olbermann's videos oh that guy's good
hasn't he decided that it's time to to
stop doing his political well i think
mission accomplished
yeah because he's in a conference
accomplishment he's really good
he was fierce fearless he is too and his
use
his his grasp on the english language is
just inspiring
holy mackerel what would that guy get
you in his crosshairs get out of the way
you don't think gentleman's quarterly
told him we're not doing this anymore
because they were paying they were
paying for the whole thing gentlemen's
quarterly is what he was doing for gq
yeah gq facebook and
the gentleman's quarterly i've been
called to gq but
i know what both those two things stand
for
yeah that uh yeah so he said
well trump's done and my
job here is complete way to go and
and and you're the guy who criticized
george w bush saying mission
accomplishments
with this big [__] dick holder that
he flew onto that aircraft carrier
when george w got off got out of the
plane
and his dick was just [__]
was it being cupped oh it was like that
the harness was just
wrapped around his dick that was a
premature announcement
oh was it ever a very embarrassing
moment on the aircraft carrier just once
a
mission accomplished like you flew in
like you just flown at mission what are
you
yeah you don't have to move that wasn't
but now we all love him
everyone loves him now that's the
amazing thing that after he was he was
the original hitler right wasn't he the
first hitler there were plenty of
protest signs
of george w bush looking like hitler
brought us into a war
yeah dick cheney was finding the whole
thing uh yeah
mission accomplished he had his dick in
balls
the one guy by the way one guy's got a
great picture with the president and the
other guy's hiding behind his
waving hands
yeah now he's just beloved now he's just
like a lovable man
elder statement a statesman yeah he
paints people too he paints soldiers
soldiers i paint i love to paint
in the in the bathtub yeah it was like
he was wasn't he hitler blithering idiot
hitler
he was he was [__] michael moore
documentary
responsible for 911. hitler hitler
and now he's just a lovable guy who
paints pictures
to call me [__] i don't like that
yeah now he's loved he was isis
yeah you know he is sizes and now just
any time he shows up hey it's w there he
is
a few years later that's all it takes
everyone likes it
and it's now it's kind of like [__] al
gore for all that environmental
right yeah well there's annoying have
there been
any ex-presidents that don't end up
beloved like even [__] nixon ended up
where people were like
you know he he gave those interviews
with the david
frost and everything and people just saw
the humanity in them did they and was
kind of like
yeah yeah we all remember like all right
you're [__] up yeah
but but people did like him and and his
legacy of opening up china and
everything kind of
made it like all right he was a good guy
i don't think there's been i think we
have such
quick we're able to quickly get rid of
do maybe a few years if trump lives uh
after he's out of the presidency i think
people can be like
wasn't he great it depends on who comes
after him
and the president and also we we stopped
because we stopped carrying they're not
policymakers anymore and then we can
just look at them as being charged
people i think that'll happen to him
though because people already knew him
before
people already knew trump before like
they didn't know but they loved
him that is true you know you know like
obnoxious was like oh you see that
you fight remember when you're fired was
like the big thing
i think in holy [__] like 10 years a
decade
yeah in like 10 years p thank you
i think people will look at trump kind
of like they look at gene simmons
where it's like they want to rock with
them no it's whole it's understood that
he's a douche bag but he's also just
kind of a wacky that he's a god of
thunder
yeah then he's got these big boots he's
a total idiot
[Laughter]
but we all love him because he's a
celebrity yeah but he's a total [__]
i don't know depending on what trump
does in office too it'll depend
i think he's doing uh but wasn't the
first bang-up john taxes going up though
[__] no they're not everyone's taxes are
going down
the problem is read my lips that yeah
the the problem is uh that that
corporations that pay a shitload of
taxes
are also getting a tax cut so it's like
oh you're good look at how much
they're getting well they've been paying
in a whole [__] load i saw it but
everyone is getting a tax cut now
whether
uh uh whatever the bill's gonna be
because i know especially in new york
uh there's gonna be a tough time with
this um state local tax thing
well you can't write off federal stuff
now right if you can't write off state
on your federal
state and local taxes you won't be able
to write off anything why not if that's
what goes through
that's part of the part of the plan yeah
we'll be paying more
then new yorkers will uh be in it
i do believe but they are considered
the wealthy see what happens it's really
annoying it is
i saw on the on the fake failing uh
uh news the msm failing
yeah on the abc fake failing news last
night they
said that that if you're
you're gonna end up paying more taxes if
you make
less than seventy five thousand dollars
a year such [__] that's
the fake failure news said utter and
complete [__]
sugar it is it's [__] okay i i just
can't
this is a an across-the-board tax cut
for everybody they said it's gonna cost
a trillion dollars
uh-huh oh now they're worried about
trillions of dollars of the deficit
when when obama was in office and it
went from [__] what was it
15 to 20 trillion or that was to help
right it was to help people how about go
[__] yourself oh okay
why can't we uh i don't want to why
can't we write stuff off that's not
right well it's hanging out
it's not finalized yet they're still
going through the senate and the house
of versions
of the bill uh like like long island
stuff why do i have to pay taxes to
federal if i've already paid it to state
i want to write stuff off
i love writing stuff off i can write it
off why don't trump want me to write it
off they allow that
yeah government allows you that what do
you mean write it off you don't even
know what
i don't know what a write-off is you
write it off
write it off i love it but yeah so we're
not going to be able to write our stuff
off anymore
don't know what you're telling me don't
know yet still there's
saying you don't know still duking it
out on that issue i know our long island
guy what's his name king
he's uh he's trying to uh he's not for
this because
people on long island pay ridiculous
amounts of property tax
and without being able to write that off
it's going to be a problem
what about this net neutrality how come
people are telling me i'm an idiot for
saying that we should definitely
have net neutrality have net neutrality
it sounds
terrible to do away with net neutrality
for us uh
you know what i don't care about net
neutrality if we're gonna
i think i'll be able to turn my computer
on and play my stupid games
that's all i care about do you play
online
yes i do then maybe this affects
you too i think it does because net
neutrality if
you do away with it yeah then the
internet provider companies
the the uh optimums the verizons the
whatever
yeah they can start tearing off internet
oh yeah the way they tear off cable
so that if how's that working out from
these days with so many other options
out there like netflix and hulu and
everything how's tiering i think because
all i hear these days from my friends my
good friend right
is yeah i cancelled cable a long time
ago
don't need it don't use it but who do
they get internet from
uh who do they get internet from right
uh i don't even know
magic people the cable company if you
can't see cable you won't get all that i
mean
i like to watch how do they watch
regular tv how do you watch like [__]
an antenna
you get a digital antenna do they go
back to that what do they do how do they
watch tv i think they do a digital
antenna which isn't like a regular
analog antenna oh i don't want to see a
sling i don't know you guys sling
totally missed the point no no i'm
talking
but uh yeah if you if you start tearing
it off like they teared off cable
right um then the market will decide and
other uh competing options will will
turn up i pay the highest tier
i'm a top tier you can't just provide
like i can't just start providing
internet
but shouldn't somebody that runs like a
video podcasting
small business yeah this is terrible for
you be super concerned why is that
because people are going to have to not
they're going to be less people that are
going to pay
for the bandwidth required to go to your
website in the future and see what's
going to happen
i have no idea so you're just like roll
the dice
just sounds uh like it'll take a long
time for it to actually happen
you're trying to roll with the punches
you're just like oh
let's say let's say the uh
the liberal media gets in bed with
corporations
which is happening oh literally which
has happened
dan rather eaten [__] pesos [__]
yuck
getting his nose in there i like it when
it smells like you've been in the chair
all day
you can hardly hear let's say
okay let's say let's say let's say
twitter and facebook and those
which i believe are liberal leaning oh
really
websites yeah that's from letterman i'm
reminded every time i'm suspended i was
just spending it for 12 hours which was
ridiculous
sarcastic i was asking kim jong-un to uh
nuke
san francisco after their uh verdict on
the the so
why can't you make a star cat like he
doesn't have twitter it's so cool
yeah and it was looked at as a threat
like really there's a
chance this might happen yeah so if
they're based on my idea if they're
going after they're like okay well we
know who anthony is yeah right
is it so crazy to believe that because
if net neutrality
is done away with internet providers are
going to be able to slow down services
to specific
websites that is true uh-huh meaning
twitter can say
we're going to give you all this money
to make sure that our website works
facebook's going to we give you all this
money to make sure our website works
quickly but
part of this deal is also some of our
more conservative
enemies let's slow down the bandwidth
compound media all of a sudden wouldn't
be as accessible
because uh the internet they've been
paid by amazon a lot of money
because they see and if bandwidth
becomes slow
it makes it a little bit difficult to
watch a live video show
certainly would then you and artie would
be pixelated
right and i'm not all uh yes
and i watch shopping i watch your show
so i can see both your beautiful faces
why we do it but you see there's
problems here for you
yeah you need net neutrality yes you do
well who's going to stand for that for
what
for them doing that what if you don't
stand for something you'll fall for
anything
right you're just saying things like i
don't get who's
like how that's what happened without
people going hey now
it's not something that the people get
to vote on you gotta call congressman
and tell them about it because congress
people the fc's the head of the fcc
wants to do away this isn't helpful jim
yeah with net neutrality
because he's in bed with the
corporations
because doing away with net neutrality
would directly benefit
the corporations that provide internet
abs this is
this whole thing is it's like a
testification of the us no it isn't
i'm saying that it doesn't make sense
what you're saying jim
and it doesn't help but yeah that does
kind of suck well it sounds uh you see
what i'm saying here
it sounds very interesting but it also
sounds like you're being a little bit of
a panicky pete
but i don't think it would help compound
media i think i really do i think that
the bigger ones would
make sure like cnn online msm like they
would make sure guys like you
who don't have this [__] completely
predicted right who's not in line
might not get the speed that they want
the libertarian point sounds like an
anti-trust issue
the libertarian point of view is to not
have the government have their hands on
internet at all
anything let the market dictate which i
totally get yeah that's true and i
usually go there but in this case
because all these giant corporations are
the ones controlling it
man they're all going to work together
he might be right about that though i
hate to say it
might be oh hold on someone's saying
that you're wrong sam or maybe he's
saying you're right
explain to me hold on i hel look at the
little guys i'm doing the mouse thing
it's not going
oh oh i see it there hold on now
hold on let's get this guy mike in new
jersey talk at the boys
mike mike hey mike hey
hey look sam a couple of years ago we
didn't have
net neutrality and none of that happened
yeah here's the difference you just said
a minute ago anthony you just said
the cable companies are failing because
of this tiered program because people
aren't buying cable right so how are the
cable companies
going to make their money back from the
fact that people are going to internet
instead of cable
they're going to get you to pay more for
internet
okay maybe he's right mike maybe sam's
right with the way
the way net neutrality works is they
want everybody treated equally so you
can't have fast lane
what they're not telling you is people
like google and amazon have already
built their own infrastructure they
already have
fat lanes what net neutrality does is it
crushes
their competition right that whole idea
of tiered service you know that meme
that went around from portugal
that was about cell phone service not
home not home internet
they're not going to want to do that to
you because you know the idea is
if you have net neutrality that would
actually be worse for anthony
than not because now he's going to get
slowed down to be able to come
to levels that you know a regular
website might have
it's not beneficial to him let me ask
you already
that's not going to change somebody is
saying um they can block specific sites
colleen and mass we're just gonna i'm
just gonna quote your thing here
they can block specific sites that you
can get for free
yes meaning that an internet provider
can decide can decide without
[__] blue just to charge you for a
website or whatever
or not or or we don't even like you
can't if you have
whatever internet provider yeah you
can't get to
compound media on our thing because it's
hate speech hate speech
yeah but that would be true because
there's too much competition
you know just by me i could go to cable
i could go to fios i've got five
different cell phone providers
if somebody starts shutting you off the
market will correct that
you know what mike i don't know about
that because a lot of times cable
companies
don't step on each other's territory
like you have comcast you have time
warner
and they all deal with certain areas and
in new york fios is not available
everywhere
fios is available in a lot of buildings
but there's places that don't have fios
yeah fios isn't available in a lot of
places government maybe
a lot of buildings aren't wired for it
they're just not wired for it too yeah
like you have to invest in it
nobody at most places don't have more
than two
maybe three television providers max
you're saying
save that max mike you're you're saying
that like where you can still get to the
websites on your cell phone because
you'll have this
at t which also owns directv
yeah is now one thing so it's not let's
say so
the cell phone providers are in bed with
those corporations and even if they
weren't
you're telling me that you're going to
go to t-mobile in your house where your
service sucks
to get things that you used to need
wi-fi for
comments what i'm saying is if you if
you look right now you'll see that
different providers are doing things
like they're giving you free netflix or
they're giving you free hulu or atp's
giving you free directv
these guys are giving you more stuff the
reason you have these localized
monopolies
is partially because of the government
so your idea to fix that is to give
government
more control of the internet what does
the government ever
not done that what what cable company
has ever run
yeah company that you haven't been like
this
sucks there's no cable provider i love
fios
only compared to what everything else is
um
yeah fios is just better it just happens
to be better
by the way in my in my house i lose
internet
on the terrace and i lose it in my
bedroom exactly so you need you're
dependent on
your internet provider do i have to get
uh i have to get a [__]
uh booster in my house a little booster
yeah
what we have now is perfect um it does
suck there's a lot of holes and there's
more things to be fixed
we're better off deregulating so you
have competition then we are regulating
more
and killing more competition because net
neutrality will end up just killing more
competition
i don't know man i i agree with you
about the government but there are times
where they do put things in place like
the government is not a hundred percent
wrong
there are times when they do regulate
what business can do and businesses are
[__]
and yeah we're not talking about mom and
pop services we're talking about
massive multi-conglomerate corporations
[Laughter]
all right thank you very much mike i
appreciate it okay all right rydo
hold on drop the call i do hate this
mouse this mouse sure is
getting cheesy yeah what do you got
there
cheesy mouse i got it you heard what i
said
yes i heard your tail uh you tell me
which
oh anyone oh my god go ahead which one
sam you made you name a number well i
know i i don't want it because they're
like saying sam is right i'm gonna go to
like
sounds awesome to me but sounds like i'm
happy to a bunch of retards on the phone
okay all right something uh peter in
canada what's up
hey hey guys how are you if we were any
better it would be a sin get ahead petey
if there was ever a time to listen to
sam this is the time to do it i know no
one wants to listen to sam
why would you say why i mean you're not
sorry you just said it you are
absolutely right sam yeah i know
absolutely right i usually end
anthony you guys should be calling your
congressman
saying oh it's so busy
[Laughter]
you know what that's gonna be a problem
when you're you're pixelated you ain't
already gonna want nothing but sitting
there
stunting your growth waiting for
something to
[Music]
[Laughter]
you guys know that john oliver thing on
net neutrality i know he's liberal media
but he did an
excellent segment on net neutrality and
it's absolutely correct with sam
i can't watch him because he's an idiot
he's very well
known researchers thank you peter yeah
but
thanks listen to him you're right buddy
our neighbor to the north we should go
to line four john in new jersey because
i have
i have a theory on this too i i i dove
into this on my on my youtube program
john in new jersey
hey important question here what's gonna
happen to the porn site
okay this is one of my big theories here
because everybody right
so on cable how often do you see porn
hold on a second okay you know it's
funny okay what i think would happen is
occasionally you can they do show porn
on cable so i think now they would just
start showing it on cable you have to
buy it on cable no no here's what it is
you're never gonna get the type of porn
on cable you can get on your [__]
phone so here's what's gonna happen i
think thank god
you have to pay for porn on cable right
you have to get like for real
like skinner you have to pay for yeah
it's not like so it's not
if you can tear off the internet legally
you're going to have to pay a whole
bunch of money for the exercise to get
the porno package
which means that for like you and me
it's like okay you get the porno package
whatever
but for for teenagers that are just
trying to jerk off for the [__]
under 30s that live with their parents
that that work here that really just
need to jerk off
they now have to go to mom and say can
you please get the porno package
for husbands that are pussy-whipped and
can't watch porn they have to go to
their wives and say
can we get to porno package please
honestly think they're gonna
tear off like specific things on the
internet
for uh uh a la carte yes
how how is that even done they could
block uh they can i.p block i mean and
they can they can location block and geo
block i saw yeah they might but
like there's other countries where it's
happening like there's a social media
package
there's a video package yeah there's
countries that have [__]
they don't want the you're talking about
the government or anything well
now you'll have to if they can charge
you more legally i mean why wouldn't
they especially since
the cable companies are failing so it's
like here's my my
ba i have basic internet so all i can
get is like what what is it
email 90 email in chat rooms it's
[__] aol again sure
email in chat rooms
before that chris hanson yeah i'd come
over there and mind everyone's beeswax
tom buzz off i think i'm right about
this one i don't know that
seems pretty extreme i think that seems
like how are they gonna do it
like right now you just go on and you go
to any website you could go to
somebody's
literally somebody's [__] myspace
page from
from 15 years ago because no company's
got control over the internet
because they're not allowed to and i
don't think any company really can get
that at this point
because they're not allowed to because
of net neutrality no i don't even think
they're capable logistically of
doing that i don't i really don't
anthony it's the future
it's the future i know you are doing a
video show
from your house whenever you want to
like i'm doing video search for myself i
know
and i'm friends with both of you yes i
guess that's true
but like and it's so easy i did that's
how i found out how easy it was i was
like if i can do it
this is easy that's how i know we're in
the future yeah we are in the future
we're in the
isn't it fun jim it's really crazy hey
uh you're almost at the point where you
can get wi-fi on your terrace
and somebody wants to help me uh oh
jesus
north carolina how do you what's up
buddy
hey what's up jimmy hey how are you ball
having a little trouble
getting the old internet in the old
bedroom
little trouble with the old sperm bank
and i bought myself
hold on elbow i bought myself a couple
of repeaters
oh try to plug a little joke around it
just didn't take ah
well let me tell you about those
repeaters what they do is they only push
half the speed to those areas so what
you need is a home network like an
orbeez
what let me ask you what's better what's
better using my my
fios uh router or using like an apple
router that i used to use
the router is your problem yeah neither
one of those i'll put like an
orbee system where you put satellite
systems around your house and it pulls
the exact same power to those areas
yeah so you'll have
it's more than repeaters it's like you
set up a brand new network
that's a network just for your apartment
and then you can put place these things
that talk to each other in different
areas it sounds very noisy i'm trying to
sleep
yep that's all i need oh god the orb did
you hear with the orb he said he talked
to the other rookie i couldn't get it
i couldn't they won't let me get a word
in edgewise so
would i still be using verizon files yes
you don't have to change your provider
you just would change
your uh your your the network itself the
the data the fighter
who but who sets this up i don't know
how to set up an orbeez anybody could do
it take 10 minutes it's easy as hell
when i still keep my original router you
could no
no no no hold on router
and two satellites you put those up and
you've got the same internet speed
throughout your
mansion of an apartment is using this no
it's the funny thing is
it's literally i walked into my he lives
in the penthouse into my hall no no but
i mean it's it's
it's a five feet away thing oh my god
the terrace is right there and it just
dies there's something to do with the
pained glass
that with double pane glass in the city
that [__] kills it yeah you try
jumping off
i believe
yeah but i won't uh is that the same as
using the old mac routers like no i'm
not going to haul my mask
i google it i know i am i'm looking at
can i can i still use
can i still use my uh my time machines
for mac
i have no idea yeah i mean you could
probably plug it into my router
you're using outdated technology though
time machines aren't outdated for
backing up your computer
pickles
you did it for the rents yeah i did it
for the rent all right you
it in take your garbage right you take
what wires were going into your router
and you plug them into your orbeez
that's it and then you move the orbi
over here they talk to each other
silently
oh crap wait a minute how do i put one
outside wow
i'm being regular guy commercial guy how
do i hold on
hold on that's the orbee question see
how do i get it outside for the orbeez
to communicate i tried it one time i
plugged it in the [__] round and the
thing didn't work oh [__] give one of
these dopey kids 50 bucks
oh yeah and then all of a sudden they
come in on my password they go to use
the orbeez oh
[__] they can't use the orbee if they're
not in your apartment that's right
sure they can you don't want anybody uh
down the street network
no you're not you can't reach it for
you're way up high but they're on the
roof
put their underwear maybe if they went
to the roof yeah they could use it yeah
you're right they're on the roof using
my wi-fi you're right now how do i use
the orbeez talk at me sam how are you
doing
how do i put an orbee outside on the
balcony don't get wet here's what you do
well easy to get wet
you stopped what you stopped farting
where can i get an orbee from tell me
best buy whatever you want how many do
you buy at one time
what the [__] you
and then for your apartment you would
probably get two of the orbee repeaters
i never want to hear the word orbee
again though
so i use one orbee and then the
repeaters are that you place all over
the place
i don't know why i even talk about net
neutrality i mean i'm asking everybody
can you bring one outside and then plug
it into an outlet outside
is that what happens that how this works
sure and then they get into any
i don't care if it's outside or inside
but that's how it works yeah i mean
and it cables the whole darn thing i
don't know it doesn't cable you don't
wire them all
together there's wireless technology yes
but you do have to plug them into the
wall
because you need a powwow but i already
got i already got repeaters and they
ain't working
they're not repeaters you're using apple
stupid no i'm not using them i'm just
using my my
router for uh my own
you have to create a new network with
the orbeez i don't know how to create a
new network
about technology jim anthony knows how
to create a network
i don't it's very easy i'm just a lump
of [__]
one of the idiots in that room
that answers the phones or whatever wow
fifty dollars to come to your apartment
they'll buy the orbee but they would
never get anything done after all the
[__]
oh my god but rob doesn't know how to do
that [__]
any of them do nico could do it no he
couldn't nico's not into
no no he couldn't i knew that all right
let me ask where's where's [__]
handsome rob
360. i hear photographers i hear [__]
uh
cameras going off yeah rob could
probably go to your house right now and
it could be ready by the time you oh my
goodness i know he couldn't
[__] housekeeper there hold on a
second robert hold on and say let's talk
to this strapping young buck in the
sweater
hold on kid hey how's it going if i was
any better it'd be a sin talk to me
about orbit do you know how to do it
uh i mean i could figure it out it's
really basic i'm sure i could figure it
out it's really basic
no but i already got my [__] uh you'd
have to go behind my thing
i can't do that i'm small behind you
[Laughter]
i have an entertainment cabinet um which
i do
we have to pull it out it's on wheels
and my [__] um
my verizon things are in there on my
verizon so what are you gonna do put the
orbee in where the horizon things are
yeah
you would take the wherever your router
is what i have plug your modem i haven't
throw it off the balcony literally four
steps
it's not it's not damn it what are you
talking about netgear
cause it says right there netgear orbee
wi-fi systems
that's an ad that's an ad for uh uh i
hate when they get yeah yeah
they're trying to click on that i can
get you to click on it you're gonna
scroll down a few
click bait it worked
so i don't know who's gonna help me out
here rob's your boy right he does your
[__] for you right i could help you
rob is a good bro boy yeah i gotta get
rob paid
give him 50 bucks to do it i want 50
bucks you don't establish his price how
much do you want to come over and do it
i'll do whatever you want to pay and how
about this in
a pair of of like saran wrap of
spandex singles
how much to do with a saran wrap singlet
[Laughter]
yeah that would dude i tried to do it
and i pulled my cabinet out the other
night and i just realized it's
overwhelming and i pushed it back in you
just got crazy looking at all the wires
yes i did uh i don't know what i'm doing
it's just crazy
i don't know what i'm doing uh why do
you try to do any of this it seems
pretty easy
it's escaped you jim it's passed no it
hasn't technology what are you talking
about success in show business
it did slip through my fingers like like
a tube of butter
too the second he has to do anything
with like an ip address though uh it
would just be over
it's really easy june the orbee would
like there'd be an orbeez flying off the
balcony
somebody would be struck and killed by
an orb there sure is i believe i've
already thought of the concierge make
sure there's no one out front
something's coming flying off this
balcony in 10 seconds
clear the area so how much would you
want
set your price um 50 bucks sounds good
yeah 50 bucks especially it seems pretty
easy yeah it's very easy it's an easy
50.
i i could do i could use 50 bucks yeah
who can't and dinner
and dinner wow and dinner like mendy's
dinner how about this i'll give you a
swanson hungry man in a [__]
a bag just get it home before it thaws
out
of swanson hungry man dinner
do you remember swanson dinners were
they terrible
i liked a good swanson dinner you know
what what's bad about
the swanson dinners uh cutting into it
after you're all
psyched it's it's took forever to cook
in the oven
and and you take a spoonful of that
turkey and it's frozen still
i hate it it was
because the cobbler would be very hot
that was like uh lava yeah and then the
stuffing and turkey would
would be frozen would be one you'd put
your fork in the stuffing you pull it
out
and you'd have a [__] perfectly
geometrically shaped
hunk of something like your mother's
[__]
trapezoid shaped gravy
i say it out loud now your mother's [__]
my father wouldn't even look up and go i
hear you pal
and then we'd laugh and have stuffing
fights
and i hated when the corn or or
something got into the cobbler
like somehow oh i would hate that too
and that terrible yeah you have to wipe
your dick off and apologize to the
problem
a mulatto cobbler i uh
make my shoes and [__] yeah
how'd that happen